en
1954 el ejército de liberación nacional
de argelia emprende su guerra de
independencia contra el colonialismo
francés
el presidente del consejo entonces guiño
le da pleno poder a los militares galos
su intervención es rápida y violenta y
los oficiales someten a una cruel
tortura de los detenidos argentinos
es así como la rebelión argelina entra
de lleno en la escena política de
francia con tal crisis que pone fin a la
cuarta república en 1958 interviene el
general y pronto presidente es charles
de gaulle los argelinos perciben en su
discurso cierta flexibilidad y se
manifiestan en reivindicación de sus
libertades el frente de liberación
nacional se pone a la cabeza con una
marcha que cubre a francia
pero los argelinos llamados franceses
musulmanes de argelia son obligados a un
toque de queda tras 20 horas
deciden saltarse lo y salir a protestar
el 17 de octubre de 1961
[Música]
en esa época movice papón es el jefe de
la policía parisina
documentos y testimonios dan fe de su
rol en la represión y asesinato de los
manifestantes
muchos de ellos fueron golpeados por la
policía otros ahogados en el río sena
a 60 años de los hechos el estado
francés ha admitido la masacre pero aún
debe esclarecer la memoria sobre la
guerra de argelia